what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we actually have some pretty
awesome dc news concerning the upcoming
film with the rock
black adam a lot of people have been
asking me to do more dc
videos and i am super excited for black
adam especially now since it's got its
entire
cast of superheroes down not to mention
i think a lot of people have been
waiting to see dwayne the rock johnson
play
a superhero and not just any superhero
one of the coolest superheroes out there
that actually classifies
as an anti-hero black adam is a
rebellious superhero which i think is
the perfect superhero for the rock to
play
and now he's joined by an incredible
cast to play the justice society of
america
including james bond himself pierce
brosnan as dr
fate i'll break down the entire cast of
the justice society of america in this
video but first
today is the last day to enter the
captain america falcon in the winter
soldier shield
giveaway giving away one here on youtube
and one on my instagram the giveaway
ends tomorrow so be sure to look in the
description down below to figure out how
to enter
so the rox black adam starts filming one
month from now
it currently has a release date of
december 22nd this year 2021
and although it probably won't happen in
his first movie there is a lot of talk
about
black adam going on to fight shazam and
superman so there's a very exciting
future for black adam in the dc universe
whatever plans they decide to go with
whether that's zachary levi shazam which
i assume it's going to be or henry
cavill superman which you never know at
this point
but as mentioned black adam in the movie
will be joined by the justice society of
america
the justice society of america is
essentially a superhero
group a team much like the justice
league or the avengers
the original group consisted of honorary
members batman and superman
wonder woman the green lantern hawkman
hawk girl
adam and dr fate plus many more but
we're going to talk about who we can
expect to see in the movie as
dc has officially confirmed who we will
see for the justice society of
america in black adam we are going to
see of course black adam himself
hawkman adam smasher cyclone and
dr fate hawkman is going to be played by
actor aldous hodge and it has been
confirmed that hawk girl
will not be appearing in the black atom
film which is a little surprising
because usually hawkman and hot girl are
involved in a romance together
and are widely associated with each
other then we have adam smasher going to
be played by actor noah continue
adam smasher has super strength and he
has control over his molecular structure
allowing him to alter the size and
density of his body
so he can become insanely huge like
giant ant-man but his power and his
strength increases proportionately to
his size
then we have quintessa swindle playing
cyclone
cyclone who was an honorary member of
the justice society of america in the
comics and current caretaker of their
headquarters
has the power of flight wind
manipulation and sound wave control
and then of course as was officially
announced yesterday
james bond himself pierce brosnan has
been announced
as dr fate now for those of you who may
not be familiar with dr fate he is
an insanely powerful character some of
his abilities include the mastery of
magic
spell casting superhuman strength
telekinesis
telepathy pyrokinesis teleportation
he has the ability to heal himself he
can do astral projection
can sometimes predict a future he has
energy negation
illusion casting and he's basically
immortal if you had to compare him to
somebody he's essentially doctor strange
and he's one of the most powerful dc
characters created
and this is going to be our first
on-screen justice society of america
now the casting of the villain is not
officially confirmed yet but several
different outlets are saying
that marwyn quinzari has been cast as
the villain
or is at least in final negotiations to
play the villain now it's not yet
confirmed who the main villain is going
to be but the illuminati reported that
he could be playing
sabic now there are two different
versions of sabic in the comics but
basically he gets his powers from hell
he's essentially a demonic version of
shazam and black adam when he says the
word sabic
lightning strikes up from the underworld
and transforms him into a super
muscular demon with super strength super
speed flight
fire breath and the ability to emit fire
blast from the palms of his hands
the cast and character list for the
justice society of america is absolutely
insane and i'm excited to see these
characters on screen and if you combine
that with
savic this movie should be an insanely
good movie and great for the debut of
the rock as a superhero
and the rock's own words about the movie
black adam and the character he said
like most kids growing up i dreamed
about being a superhero
as a kid superman was the hero i always
wanted to be
but a few years into my fantasy i
realized that superman was
the hero i could never be i was too
rebellious
too rambunctious too resistant to
convention and authority
despite my troubles i was still a good
kid with a good heart i just like to do
things my way
now years later as a man with the same
dna i had as a kid my superhero dreams
have come
true i'm honored to join the iconic dc
universe
and it's a true pleasure to become black
adam
black adam is blessed by magic with the
powers equal to superman
but the difference is he doesn't toe to
the mark or walk the line
he's a rebellious one-of-a-kind
superhero who'll always do what's right
for the people but he does it his
way truth and justice the black adam way
so in the comics there are versions of
black adam who is a true super villain
that is not who we are going to get we
are going to get the
anti-hero black atom and so far it's
looking to be a great
movie with a great cast so let me know
what you think about this
in the comments down below do you like
the casting of pierce brosnan as
dr fate be sure to subscribe for more dc
and of course marvel updates don't
forget to check out the giveaway details
in the description down below
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me